Now, folks, I've said it
during a deposition
for the National Park Service,
and I'll say it again:
(bleep) the Eagles.
Now, sure...
they're noble American symbols,
but when it comes
to the NFL kind,
Eagles can also be traitors.
The president announcing
the Philadelphia Eagles
will not be visiting
the White House tomorrow
to celebrate
their Super Bowl victory
due to the national anthem
controversy.
The Eagles,
who won Super Bowl LII,
apparently wanted to send
a smaller group of players.
A handful
did not plan to attend.
Yes. And by "handful,"
she means about 76.
The only members
of the Eagles organization
who did plan to attend were...
(reading):
And to be fair,
we don't know how many people
are in Swoop.
There could be two or three
or the entire
2017 Golden State Warriors.
We don't know.
Even so, Trump had no choice
but to kick the flag-hating
Eagles to the curb,
saying that...
(reading):
Take that, Eagles!
Even though, technically,
no Eagles players
ever took a knee
or stayed in the locker room
during the anthem.
But they obviously hate America.
Why else would they have
willingly
beat the crap out
of the Patriots?
(laughter, applause)
And... why else would we have
seen so many photos
of the Eagles kneeling
on Fox yesterday?
STEPHANIE RUHLE:
I want to show you a-a clip
from Fox News last night
where they played
Eagles players kneeling.
Eagles' tight end Zach Ertz
tweeted this reaction.
"This can't be serious.
"Praying before games
with my teammates
"well before the anthem is
being used for your propaganda.
"Just sad. I feel like
you guys should have
been better than this."
Oh, sorry, Ruhle, but, no,
we're not going to be better
because in Trump country,
we be best.
(laughter)
And sure, fact-lovers whined
enough about this that Fox
technically issued an apology
for taking the kneeling out
of context by taking pictures
of players kneeling in prayer
before the game and using them
as evidence of protest
during the anthem.
But come on!
You can't let a little thing
like context get in the way.
(laughter)
Because without context,
I can clearly see people
disrespecting our flag
all over the place.
Look at the pope crapping
all over old glory.
And check out The Bachelor
insulting our troops
just like that.
And then there's this
anti-American dirt bag.
Boom. Ugh.
Look at that cocky ginger
spitting in the face
of our great nation's military.
I can't think of anyone
less American.
For more, citizen journalist
Niccole Thurman.
-What's up?!
-(cheers and applause)
-Niccole.
-What's up?
What's up?
What is up?
Niccole, let's talk football.
We know
Trump disinvited the Eagles.
But in an act of generosity,
he still invited Philly fans
to The White House to celebrate
the national anthem.
It's a great idea, right?
Look, Jordan,
I hate to say this.
Donald Trump is
a master deal-maker,
but this was a bad deal.
He said "no" to a group
of Super Bowl-winning
millionaires in suits,
and "yes" to a thousand
Philadelphia sports fans?
These guys? (scoffs)
MAN: Fans pulled down
traffic lights,
started fires
and tipped over cars.
-(shouting) -Some climbed on
the awning of the Ritz-Carlton.
This fan hopped on top
of a police van.
You have glass everywhere.
Cars that were set on fire.
MAN: Authorities rubbed
hydraulic fluid on light poles.
It didn't work,
but the Eagles are happy.
-(man shouting)
-KLEPPER: Oh.
(laughter, applause)
-Come on, Niccole.
-Yeah.
These are the common man,
salt of the earth people.
No, Jordan,
they're "salt the earth people."
Okay. Nothing survives them.
Like, remember
that cute little robot
from 2015 who was hitchhiking
around the world?
He was so excited
to explore the U.S.
Then he went to Philly.
-And they beat him to death!
-(audience groans, gasps)
Philly fans are lawless,
raging maniacs,
and Trump invited them
into his home, The White House,
which, by the way, is a rental.
-Okay, so...
-(laughter, groaning)
So you're afraid they'll burn
down The White House?
No! No, I'm afraid they're gonna
get jobs in The White House.
(laughter)
Listen, Trump loves bruisers,
okay?
If he sees a guy whose résumé is
a sock full of batteries,
and a pocket full
of (bleep) yous,
that guy's gonna get a job!
The fan who intentionally
threw up on a little girl?
Hey, you're the director
of Health and Human Services.
(laughter, groaning)
The fans who crushed the
Ritz-Carlton awning-- in charge
of infrastructure.
That's their job now.
And how about a fan
who punched a horse,
and then sued the cops
whose horse he punched?
Hey, man, congrats.
You're the new
Secretary of Punching Horses.
-It's an EPA job.